il vous pose des questions oui beaucoup
pas mal vous répondez à tout
non non et gazés comment vous faites
pour l'exaspérer par exaspérer à
s'effacer et des pieds c'est drôle parce
qu'il est très généreux il ya des petits
trucs de gâchis ça m'énerve par exemple
se frotter des allumettes et a pas
besoin moi j'aime bien l'odeur après ou
écrits sur des bouts de papier ça
salinaires beaucoup mais ça dépend celle
ci et puis de perdre six mois je suis
assez désormais je perds un peu tout ça
ça les nerfs au elle est merveilleuse
avec moi mais je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
dans sa tête
je ne sais pas exactement telle est son
attitude elle est si délicieuse que
parfois je me demande si si elle n'est
pas comme ça avec moi un petit peu par
compassion en se disant il le peut tête
il a besoin de moi j'ai peur des froids
que ce soit ça parce qu'elle est
tellement délicieuse elle est tellement
adorable
j'ai peur que ce soit et je voudrais pas
je voudrais jamais que qu'on fasse
quelque chose pour me faire plaisir
enfin je voudrais que que tout ce
qu'elle fait avec moi ce soit pour lui
faire plaisir à l is mais rarement en
colère contre moi ici mes choix deux
fois en colère et une fois c'était en
juin ont joué au
complète je crois et moi je suis très
mauvaise jouer c'est vrai je déteste
perdre et je suis parti de là ils font
tous il faisait exprès de me faire
perdre mais vraiment il exprès de me
faire peur pour faire pleurer c'est vrai
que ça marche à chaque fois un jour je
suis partie de la table et il a couru
vers moi comme un fou il m'a dit petit
quand tu vas te remettre à la table et
j'y suis allée comme ça ça m'a marqué
oui